hi everybody I'm Nancy O'Dell and we are
bringing you the et interview
and the couple with the lowest combined
total of judges scores and viewer votes
therefore leaving right now is James and
Peter
what's nice about going today is you're
not really going anywhere we're still
here tomorrow we've made it all the way
we've literally been here every step of
the way the entire competition and it's
hard to ask for much more than that
you know I I'm so proud of the dances we
did tonight we nailed him we killed it
in fact I hope there's an uproar on
Twitter and I'm sure my friends won't
disappoint it but it's not an anything
against the other competitors they're
all great people and we're all so
incredibly different he did such an
amazing job tonight two incredible
hard-hitting dancers and I couldn't have
asked any more from him honestly this
whole season has been such a joy and a
pleasure and yeah we brought my
choreography skills up he's he's amount
of talent and ability I had to really
make sure I was stepping up to the plate
and giving him you know the best that I
could give it really is awesome being in
the finals Pete and I've got really
close throughout this competition I'm
gonna miss her is their last week
dancing together wasn't it
I'm actually really sad about it still
dance together after this I will sign up
for the local ballroom competition and
I'll pick Hughes my partner
cool stay through that in their course
they did can't bother us about that
anymore Kenya yeah we definitely going
out for a drink after this